1er mai selon la jolie tradition à tous
les carrefours paris a vu fleurir les
paniers des marchands druguet qui à tous
les passants rendent la fleur du bonheur
la peur de l'espérance le 1er mai
synonyme de fête du travail et du muguet
normalement à cette date les marchands
d'un jour sont dans la rue et voient un
moyen de se faire de l'argent de poche
ou pour ces deux nantais en 1996 là vous
devez acheter combien de bras la 250
ça fait un investissement de combien de
sang vous pensez à rentrer dans vos
frais quoi ça dépend si tout est vendu
on devrait s'y rend vraiment nui le
200 francs donc on les fleuristes aussi
c'était une belle aubaine
cette même année en 1996 il estimé que
la vente du muguet allait leur rapporter
l'équivalent de 38 millions d'euros
rien à voir avec les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui car depuis le milieu des
années 2000 les ventes baissent enfin
depuis deux trois ans les gens moins
d'engouement à cette fête cette
tradition mais c'est léger en
pourcentage peut-être 10 15% pour avoir
ce petit brin de muguet les français ont
dépensé 38 millions d'euros uniquement
chez les fleuristes en 1996 en 2019
c'était 22 millions d'euros chez les
fleuristes mais aussi chez les vendeurs
de rue nous savons oui beaucoup plus on
partait même en vacances une semaine
entière avec mes parents et nous étions
cinq enfants aujourd'hui grâce aux
commandes et la veille et le 1er mai en
il n'y avait que 5 % des foyers français
qui avait acheté du muguet le 1er mai la
tradition se perd du travail le 1er mai
2020 et ses fleuristes fermer ces
vendeurs de rue interdite et c'est
france est confiné ne risque pas de
relancer la flamme de ce petit brin
pourtant porte bonheur
[Musique]